hello everyone my name is Bumi and I'm
here to bring you talk about enhancing
ankling rehearsals with technology but
first of all a little bit about me
so I come from this corner of the planet
in the corner little map that you never
look at probably he in this little small
city called Bandung Indonesia so this is
the first third largest city of my
country per population and it is the
home of the uncle oh I was born and
raised in Bandung and now I'm currently
a software engineer for hanging which is
based in Tokyo Japan we are a
business-to-business cloud security
provider and we are also looking for
incense so if you are interested in
having an internship in Tokyo come talk
to me later I have been an aqua
enthusiast for over 10 years I've been
since I joined my high school club and
since then I've been a performer in
Italy Greece Malaysia and many other
countries I've been in conducted in
several concerts and performances but
I've been interested in programming for
a whole lot more than that so naturally
I've been tinkering with software
solutions to the problems I faced in
uncle rehearsals which has inspired me
to bring this talk to you so first of
all before we get into this talk have
has anyone ever heard of uncle in before
one ok nice so this is the uncle it's
basically made all of bamboo it has a
frame and two tubes two one this small
tube and one the larger tube both of
those tubes when shaken when the
instrument is shaken both of those two
produce a sound a specific note so the
vibration of those the length of those
tubes are are what determine the the
pitch or the note of this of the young
clone so that's why we have a bigger
ankle that produces lower notes and
smaller ranking that produces higher
notes so when we know that um one uncle
only produces one note so we need
a lot of unclean to produce a whole song
right so we can you can think of one
angklung as representing one key on a
piano so the bigger angklung are the
keys are the keys on the left of the
piano which are the lower notes and the
smaller angklung are the are the keys on
the right side of the piano which are
the higher notes so this is an example
of an uncle an orchestra you can see
here there are about like 20-ish 30-ish
players each holding one to five uncle
in in this particular case probably
about four of uncle each person yeah and
they are led by a conductor and several
other accompanying instruments so here
I'm going to show you a little a clip to
show you about what uncle really can
produce
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so anyone recognize that song of course
yes
the Star Wars main theme so yeah that
just gives you a picture of what kinds
of song a long-term can or the young
Queen can play so basically any kind of
song that you can imagine it can be
arranged and played by the anklet from
classical music to soundtracks to
popular music to anything actually so
yeah now we get to the problem where
there are a lot of uncle owned in a team
right which with all kinds of shapes and
sizes and we have we have several people
that are ready to hold the uncle oh so
the problem is how do we distribute
those uncle to those people well you
might think well we can just distribute
them randomly right we can just give
them whatever I'm think they want and
well it is kind of possible but there
are there are constraints that we need
to consider that makes us we can't we
can't distribute the uncle randomly but
first to give you a clearer picture of
that of what those problems are what
those constraints are I need to
introduce you to the sheet music which
is specifically for the young clue or
music score or whatever you like to call
it so when we think about sheet music
the the idea the picture that comes to
mind is something like there's probably
all right well uncle does not use this
kind of sheet music it's different from
the Western Western sheet music but
instead it uses something called the
cipher notation or in Indonesian it is
called not Anka which is which can be
literally translated as number notes so
sorry to disappoint you here but this
cipher has nothing to do with
cryptography rather the cipher here is
called it's called a cipher notation
because the cipher here shows that the
denotes the musical pitches that we hear
are encoded into numbers so this is an
example of the Hong Kong sheet music
as you can see here there are several
notes and you read this sheet music from
the top left to the bottom right those
lines are bar lines and each each beat
is represented by one column there so
the the numbers there represent notes
and the the dots above or below the
numbers represent the octaves so if
there are more dots on the bottom that
means it's the same note but with a
lower octave and if there are dots above
the numbers that means the same note but
on a higher octave and then the numbers
with slashes on them they mean the the
flats and sharps so if it has a forward
slash then that means that note with a
sharp and if it has a back slash then it
means that note but with a flat so when
really we read left to right and then
the numbers in the same column are
played in the same beat at the same time
so as you can see here there are several
notes like for example these two notes
are played at the same time so they
cannot be say be played by the same
person because it is it it is hard to
play two angklung at the same time on
the other hand there are notes like this
they're only they're only appear like
one beat of throughout the whole song
which means we cannot just give one
player that note otherwise he would just
be left on the stage only playing one
note and only playing like one second or
two for the whole song which is kind of
sad for that player right so we have to
take care of those things we also have
to take care that one player does not
get all the big UNK long and like for
example one player gets all the the
lower notes and all one player gets all
the higher notes because that would mean
the player there the players hands would
become full with the smaller angklung
and it would be hard to
reach them so we need a good balance of
big and small anklet for each player so
this is an example of a good uncommon
balance so as you can see here this one
player here has the big angklung which
is like the length of each the height of
shoulder and then there are also smaller
ankle in which he can hold on his arm
I want his hand I mean so there are
various sizes of Hong Kong and we need
to take care to distribute them as to
not as to have a good balance so how do
we solve this problem well before before
we thought about how to create some kind
of like algorithm or program to solve it
we used to solve it manually using this
kind of table this is called we used to
call it a bungee table which or a
collision table which denotes that which
notes appear together with other notes
in the same score so you can see you can
see the rows there are this individual
notes and then if you follow the notes
to the right of them you can see every
square is connected to another note so
we color code them by how much they they
appear together and the darker note the
darker squares mean they can absolutely
cannot be played together and the
lighter squares mean that well yeah they
can be played together and they will
collide once or twice but there has to
be another player that covers that
specific instance so I I thought about
how to solve this using using program
using technology so I wrote up an
algorithm for this so first of all we we
take a sheet I'm going sheet music which
is as you can see here this row column
lie layout looks like something input in
a specific type of program right which
is yeah it gets did a spreadsheet
program so we usually write in a
spreadsheet program and then
we extracted extract the important parts
which is the notes and then we we divide
it we divide the notes according to the
the order we read the lines and then we
stitch them together into one one huge
line and then this is how we actually
read the music but we can't have that on
a piece of paper so we divide it like
this and then after we we stitch them
together we read it as usual from left
to right and then we take note of which
notes appear where how how many times
they appear in that score and also which
notes they appeared closer together to
which which other note so basically this
is the code in Python I wrote for that
and basically it means that the basic
idea is that we add we have two
dimensional array and we have we add the
notes to those columns until we reach
the end of the score and then we process
those those information until we get two
pieces two key pieces of information
which is what I like to call the
collision table and the play time
information the collision table other
means like which note appears closer
together - which other note how many
times like there's a formatting or there
but basically the the Q W and E's
represent the the ones twos and threes
and in this specific example the the the
one note in the to note the daughter
note and the Ray note appears together
about 13 times and then the doughnut and
the me note appear about 40 times so
basically we we count the appearances of
those notes and how much they appear
together with
other other notes and the play time
information is like how many beats or
yeah how many beats does that note or
uncle play in that song like we can
quantify those and then we can calculate
the collision table using this kind of
algorithm and so basically this
algorithm means that you can see here
that we iterate through the score we we
look at the uncle owns per column and
then and then we find in the same column
which notes appear together and then we
count the the occurrence of those notes
and then we until we go go through the
whole score and then after that we get
that kind of table and then for the play
time information it's all so simple we
calculate the play time and we go
through the score and then we calculate
like we count how many how many times
this this note appears in the score so
if we find this note then we just
increment the note by one or according
to duration so if if there's a like a
health beat then we increment the number
of we increment the number of these by
house beat and so on so that way we we
get those that this these two kind of
information and what do we do with those
information then we optimize the
distribution based on the these three
constraints so these three constraints
are the most important constraints we
need to consider when creating a
dumpling distribution which is we need
to minimize the number of collisions
which is we need to minimize one player
the occurrence of
we're getting to including that appeared
together in the score but we need to
maximize the amount of play time for
that player so that player that player
needs to play as much as possible
without their uncle colliding with each
other and then we need to achieve a good
balance of size of the alcohol so we
need to give them like big uncle and
also smaller uncle so they can they can
play the angklung more comfortable so
this is kind of like this kind of like
optimization problem in mathematics
there there is there are lots of ways to
solve this optimization problem I came
up with an algorithm that basically we
assign a weight to each of those to each
of the players and then when when we we
go through all of the outcome that we
need to distribute and then for for each
of the anchoring that we need to
distribute we we assign a weight based
on the collision table so if the
collision table we look up the collision
table and we see if the if the number is
high then that means the way is
decreased which means don't give the
anchoring to that player because it will
collide with that players other angklung
and we also look at the play time and we
we decrease the weight based on the play
time of that alone so which basically
means if that player already has include
which plays a lot in that score don't
give this an - I'm going to that player
because it will make that player play
too much we need to distribute the the
play time so that every player has like
a rough equal number of of play time and
then we also look at if the angklung is
considered a low note uncle or bigger
Anglo and then that that player already
holds a bigger uncle then we should not
give the bigger uncle into that there
because that player already has a big
outlook so we need to find those players
that still have small clones that still
have not too much play time so we can
add more play time to that to that
player and yeah we sort the the weight
and then we pick which which uncle that
in that pool of ankling that we need to
distribute has the lowest player has the
highest weight and then we give it to
that player so we iterate a bunch of
times this is probably not as optimized
as I would like but there are much more
ideas out there that I haven't explored
yet including there was a talk this
morning that talked about also talking
about optimization problems and how to
find the optimal optimal value and I
also would like to try that out in this
problem because this is basically a
general problem an optimization problem
and we there are a lot of ways to solve
this so there are many possibilities for
future improvements of the the way we
distribute uncle along with with
technology and uh and also there are a
lot of problems other than this
distribution problem that we can solve
with technology but this field is still
[Music]
it's still being explored by a lot of
players and it's it's just just starting
to progress so we'll see in the future
if if a lot of problems like these that
we that we see and uncle playing can be
solved in the technology and also in
this
I kind of skipped on a lot of details
including like how to read key
signatures and how to calculate them how
to convert notes from relative notes the
absolute notes etc but since I still
have time I'd like to come back and
[Music]
explain to you so here we have maybe not
this one
yeah this one will have a key signature
which is the dough here equals F so
these these notes these number notes are
still relative they don't show an
absolute number absolute note like cdefg
so we still need to convert these these
relative notes to an absolute note like
CD etc according to the key signature
and the key signature information is
above so it's just a simple matter of
looking up in the in a predefined table
we store which maps each letter to a
relative note and then if we find that
relative note then we just look up that
table and then convert it into a into a
absolute note which is what the uncles
are are labeled in so these uncles are
labeled with absolute notes instead of
relative notes so every time we switch a
song or switches key signature those
uncle ins play a different number and
then the players have to convert which
so what it what note they are playing
with that uncle oh yeah
[Music]
yeah I guess basically that's it
and if you want to are interested in an
internship in Japan you can visit this
URL here thank you and I have time for
questions too so if anyone has any
questions
wow yeah I am considering so the
question was am i considering or using
using a mirror oh yeah yeah
solitude for this problem and yeah
actually I haven't explored a lot of
those automated solvers yet but yeah I
think it's a it's a good prospect for
for our sample players
ah
haha okay so the question was if if we
have several songs in a performance then
do those players change their uncle and
the switch or or whatever actually we
don't so we in in the rehearsals we have
to consider every song that we are going
to perform in the same performance and
we have to optimize all of those songs
together so the the the distribution of
the angklung itself does not change
throughout the performance so they hold
the same angklung and so we need to take
consideration of all of those songs
together as a whole performance yeah yes
[Music]
okay so the question was is there gonna
be new music that people write because
the the distribution problem is solved
easier right well actually first of all
we don't write a original music that
often in on cologne we usually try to
transcribe or range young songs that are
already made and then we translate them
to angklung so that we can play them but
if you are asking are are we going to
decide to arrange more complicated songs
or more harder songs that to distribute
well maybe not because actually when we
decide to play a song or arrange a song
we just think about we don't we don't
really consider like if if the
distribution is hard or not because we
only know if it's hard or not after the
song is made after the song is arranged
right like we already we only know the
distribution of the notes after the song
is arranged so before that we can
imagine if the song is hard to
distribute or not and because since this
is a optimization problem we can't
really find like the best song - the
easiest song to distribute or like the
best distribution there has to be like
it depends on the conductor and also the
manager of the team like how they decide
to distribute the angklung so yeah there
can be lots of different distributions
from from the same song even so yeah yes
oh that's a good question so the
question was does this algorithm can
consider our would consider player
experience people that have a lot of
experience Uncle intent to be able to
handle more uncle easier easily and like
different sizes of uncle easily and they
can also handle collisions more easily
then they know what to do when their
uncle collides just one or another and
so on
well that was an idea I I consider it
before but after several iterations
maybe I thought that it doesn't matter
that much because you can't really
quantify player experience and then
translate it to a criteria of that
optimizing optimization problem like for
example if that is that players five
years of experience then how do you
determine the weight of that player
relative to the other players so yeah
it's it's a good point to consider but
it's really hard to quantify that's all
the other questions
all right then thanks for listening
[Applause]